there's lots of debate about who's the
greatest football player of all time to
me there's only one winner cristiano
ronaldo he's not only the top scorer in
the history of football but i think he's
the guy that proves it's not just about
talent it's about work ethic when i
dinner with him in italy over four hours
i just got a sense of the kind of guy he
is unbelievably driven incredibly
focused doesn't party looks after
himself works out trains every day and
just wants every day to get up and be
the best in the world and for many many
years in my estimation he has been and
you get your messy fans of course you do
there's only one christian
the thing about vegans is they always
look so miserable doesn't it they always
look like what they really need is a
good hot steak that's probably what
they're all thinking because who would
voluntarily want to be a vegan it's so
riddled with hypocrisy the ones who say
well i'm doing it to save the animals
really because most of you drink almond
milk eat almonds and avocado how do you
think those get made i'll tell you by
the slaughter of billions of bees in
california every year over a five-week
period billions of bees get killed so
that vegans can have their almond milk
and avocado and yet they dare to lecture
me about animal welfare no
not having it cheer yourselves up and
get a nice steak inside you and we'll
just pretend it never happened
i like joe biden personally i think he's
a decent man but very sadly i think what
we're seeing is that he got the big job
too late he's about to turn 80 and his
early tenure so far as president has
been frankly a disaster he comes across
as somebody too old for the job finds it
all too much i think certainly nothing
like the fire brand senator he used to
be in his younger days i think that
america's got real problems now with
their economy with the way they've
handled the pandemic with the division
in the country and he's doing nothing to
solve these problems and ultimately
america needs someone to come in and fix
their big big problems as we do in our
country but i don't think joe biden's a
guy and you could see a situation where
if he carries on this badly that donald
trump
could actually get re-elected and if
that doesn't give people pause of
thought nothing will
i think facebook gets a bad rap they've
done some pretty ruthless commercial
things and they deserve to be held
account for it i think they should treat
themselves as a proper publishing
platform with all the regulation that
comes with that which newspapers and
television
companies have but i do think they've
been an extraordinary social media
platform that have also done a lot of
good which we never read about anymore
over a billion people i think now use
facebook the way it connects families
and friends around the world i think has
been an amazing thing for the planet yes
there are problems with facebook yes it
probably got too big too quickly and
they've got to work out how to solve the
problems but i would say that
more than not it's a force for good
[Music]
you know one of the things that i really
can't stand and i apologize in advance
to anyone who i may know who has one of
these i can think of one immediately
sharon osbourne was gonna be shouting at
me for saying this but people that carry
little dogs around in handbags that's
not what dogs should be carrying and if
you've got a dog that small get a bigger
one nothing against little dogs they
look a bit ridiculous when you see them
in the street poking out of handbags
it's embarrassing